before she can do anything she's choke
slammed by Valic and runs to a seemingly
unused storage room for safety once
again there's a mirror and for the third
time now it would be connected to Valic
she's encircled by five candles which
light themselves and she realizes that
she's standing in a pentagram but as she
runs for the exit she's stopped in her
tracks by an army of robed figures who
abduct her and bag her head forcing her
to join their ranks Frenchie eventually
finds her but when he uncovers her head
she's been possessed by valet and she
arates him into a pillar which he's
pinned against this is the next lot IAL
step in the mirror metaphor Val had used
mirrors to make Irene fear her future as
a nun and now that she's realized that
life by becoming one valik would
literally possess her it's bringing
those fears to fruition the possessed
Irene hurls targeted insults about
Frenchie being the village idiot it's a
Trope that we've seen a lot in the
exorcism genre going back to the
Exorcist however he's able to use the
vial hanging from her neck to smear the
blood of Christ on her face calling back
to the beginning of the adventure when
she smeared the paint on the girl's nose
this has an immediate and Powerful
effect exercising the demon from her